hey looking good today right not so much
I just come back from the Indy 500
yesterday I'm posting that vlog tomorrow
so look for that I'm almost done editing
it was taking me forever so it's like
you know what I'm just going to post
this easy vlog first and then I'll post
a new vlog tomorrow
I slept in till almost 2:00 p.m. today
the only reason that I woke up early was
to take the dog for a walk around 8 a.m.
and then we both got back in bed so here
we are many hours later just got a
shower really ready to start the day
Maddie and I are gonna pack up hit the
road go to Matt's house to watch the
first game of the Stanley Cup Playoffs I
was so excited because hopefully we're
gonna be able to get some tickets to go
to San Jose I'm not sure I'm so have you
so much fun this is pretty much the
ideal matchup because we're like okay
it's a pennant the Sharks are in it it's
not gonna be that far to go to San Jose
do you want to go to San Jose
I got through a French you got me a
present
it'll be here how scared to find out
what this is but your pocket looks
really clean very nice did you clean
today hockey game gun Jesus don't get
that close
is the surprise here yet
no but I think you're really gonna love
it
surprise when are we going to the game
is the question for ya yes cuz game 3 is
June 4th that would be a little tough we
could do it they couldn't do it I don't
think we should because we're going to a
party on Friday prize surprise it's not
a surprise he's so dirty he needs it
another girl hey have you got B who's
all coming today do we have friends that
will be attending have I not been making
that joke forever
the point is 1 0 this job stealer
ok if I saw that joke oh but not opposed
to it I've never seen it I've never seen
it I posted it on snapchat who I don't
watch of wolves
you didn't I posted the snapchat Genesis
I stole the joke don't prove it prove it
I'm not getting in the middle I actually
heard using it and I think that's why I
got stuck inside his head this is going
to Vegas with us or what these up these
months we're going to get some food like
my new kicks
I thought you being her Brussels sprouts
cuz they hurt your tummy they do but
Savannah same Chipotle potato hash
sounds incredible did you get
cucumber met you alright
it tastes like health where's our food
how much time until the game starts
again for Keener's
great footage on here I was like just
you were you going back talkie show we
over our surprise this man Oh baby
looks like oh okay one format - - I
don't like basketball we watch hockey
believers Charlie throw the brick the
city tonight get it oh we threw it in
front I thought I'd have another candy
today was gonna be the day that I didn't
eat candy but I screwed up
everybody needs to go over and now it's
really exciting I think we might die
tonight form go sharks shut your face oh
I'm so satisfied we don't even need the
pizza cancel
Oh everybody we win tell you one thing
Baker's one game - yay - next Wow Wow
good job pens hi Matt will be private
together real thing